a lot of people right now you know the
entire everyone needs to be resilient
going through what we're going through
and
and managing and doing so successfully
so i think that that's a really
important skill to have
[Music]
and bloom thank you so much for being on
my show how are you
thank you so much for having me i'm
delighted to be here i'm great you know
six months into quarantine but still
still surviving just can't complain how
are you i i'm doing i'm doing fine but i
see only one plant and you said yeah
you have 100 you have 100 plants in your
in your apartment
and three trees right yes this is one of
the trees
and most of the plants are downstairs
it's hard to like
carry them up the stairs of course of
course in my living room i've basically
turned it into a greenhouse
during quarantine i've had a lot of free
time so i've been
doing gardening indoors because i don't
have any outdoor space unfortunately
and also painting so i love it i love it
okay so i i've been hearing that a lot a
lot of people
have been taking up uh botanics and
gardening lately so this is
it's definitely very interesting and
it's like i figure if you can't go
outside might as well bring the outside
in 100 100 so and i mean it's a really
fascinating journey that that you've had
that i'm and i'm very excited
i'm very excited to hear about you know
the insights that you've gained along
the years
from running two accelerators in new
york one of them the german accelerator
another one ellis
moving on to early stage venture capital
helping european and israeli startups
break into the u.s market with angular
ventures as the head of platform but you
started out in corporate already started
out
in mobile developer outreach through for
facebook right
well actually my first job ever after
college was at goldman
as hr yeah hr so that was um
a great start you know i really enjoyed
starting my career
um at a large company especially goldman
um
is a fantastic place to work and got to
meet you know and work with some
really incredible smart people 100 so i
have to ask
the german accelerator uh i would like
i mentioned i was looking i was looking
forever for what is the name of the
german accelerator
and you just helped me clarify a second
ago but please clarify for everybody
watching this
so the german accelerator's name is
german accelerator
which is probably the most german way to
like come up with an accelerator name
you have no idea how many times when i
worked there people would be like what's
the name of the german accelerator like
the german accelerator
i'm sure i'm sure so it's it's almost
like it's topical now
i mean it works a ton of startups have
gone through it and you know the
program's doing quite well but
uh whatever means people talk about it
more it
obviously works but you're not from
germany you're from france originally
right
so my dad's american he's a jew from the
bronx and then my mom was from paris
um so i basically spent i was born in
london
then lived in paris for a bit and when i
was three i moved to new york
um still spending my summers in france
typically in paris
or the south specifically basque country
um
and then in new york i grew up in
westchester i went to the french
american school so i still
you know speak french and you know try
to keep that connection alive
but i'm very like americanized in my
culture
no i don't speak german not german at
all um
fortunately that wasn't a prerequisite
to working at the german accelerator
how do you go from hr goldman sachs to
mobile developer outreach at facebook to
running two accelerators at the same
time in new york
great question i would love to say that
i had this like big grand plan for my
career of like i'll do this
and then i'll do that no not at all this
is not planned
it just happened and i don't get me
wrong i'm very happy with the outcome of
it
um but the mindset i had when i started
my career
was um or at least my first job at
goldman was
i love this this is fantastic you know
i'm supporting
um basically my role there was in
learning and development and helping
the 9000 plus engineers that worked at
goldman
know all everything they needed to know
from technical side
all the way to soft skills um and
it was i was there for about a year and
a half
and i i thought i was gonna be a lifer
like i
i really died with the corporate culture
my dad had worked there for a long time
um and you know i think especially
coming straight from college
you know being in a like part of the
whole like analyst class the summer
training program so it's just a lot of
fun
um and then i kind of
i knew ultimately i didn't want to be in
hr long term
it just wasn't exactly um you know i
really enjoyed it but i knew that
i didn't want to make a career in that
now when you say hr just to clarify
because there's a lot of different
facets in hr so what specifically were
you
were you working on within yeah so
learning and development and i was
specifically on the goldman sachs
university
uh technology team so that team i was
very lucky
in that i was placed on the tech team
right because you get accepted and then
you go to goldman sachs university
and they have different teams aligned to
the different divisions
and you know most people wanted to be on
the ibd team
or securities right like the sexy sexy
teams and i was like no put me on tech
this is like i find interesting i want
to be with my techies
and you know back then like i think
especially in new york tech wasn't cool
and i was very lucky that i got placed
on that team i got to meet
you know a ton of really great engineers
and work with them
and also happened to fall into this tech
world which i
fell in love with and you know after
working with engineers for a while i
realized okay i really am into this tech
scene
how can i get more into this and
the logical conclusion was okay go to a
tech company
and one of my best friends from cornell
she was
at facebook working on the fb start
program
so she kind of pulled me in it happened
very quickly
um and i joined yeah i joined at the end
of 2015.
um and it was an amazing experience i
mean it was a very small team we were
three people
and we were running a program with at
the time over 12 000 startups
all around the world so it was very much
a scaled program but we were able to
support them
in a skilled manner do events all around
the world
give them benefits mentorship from
facebook community etc so you're saying
there wasn't a you know this grand plan
but i do see a pattern
i am you know working on a pattern here
that you're starting out
sort of in in finances but you're go
you're gravitating towards tech and then
you find yourself
helping twelve thousand startups within
facebook so it is now very logical as to
how you went
to create two accelerators and then you
end up helping
uh helping uh you know leverage the
portfolio companies for
an early stage venture capital fund like
angular ventures
absolutely so i will say that you know
like when i was still in school and i
didn't know what i wanted to do
i just knew that i wanted to have like a
positive impact whatever it was that i
was doing
and then fell into the tech world and
then ended up working with startups at
facebook and that's when i knew
okay i like fell in love with the
startup game
and this is what i wanted to do for the
rest of my life right yeah
supporting startups hopefully helping
them achieve their goals
and you know ideally i would love to be
involved with building the next google
or you know other
big tech company and um
it was a really awesome experience you
know i think especially being in silicon
valley i moved there in 2015.
facebook was growing incredibly quickly
at the time there was nothing quite like
it
i will say just from a social
perspective moving from downtown
manhattan to
menlo park was a little fast
it was a bit of a change um but it was
an incredibly exciting experience and
one that you know i was very fortunate
to be a part of
um and we were i was on the platform
partnerships team
um and the thing with facebook is things
change really quickly
from one day to the next so after
about a year and a half working there i
knew that i wanted to come back to the
east coast i
most of my family and friends are here
and
i also saw that the new york city tech
scene was starting to really
come into its own and i wanted to be a
part of that because it was like
there's something really there's
something here and i miss the new york
energy and there's something really
special about new york
so i came back and i kind of did
something that's like
i feel like most people would discourage
doing it but
i thought it was fantastic is after
working at goldman and facebook
i was tired you know both were very
intense jobs
working you know late night every night
working most weekends
and i was like i need a break so you go
and you run towards elevators at the
same time
it makes sense well before that i took
six months off
to to travel the world i went to israel
for the first time which was amazing
and um you know went to a bunch of other
places
and i've you know i thought like being
somewhat of a workaholic i thought i
would be so bored
during my time off and that was not all
the case i was just having a blast
i was like i could do this for a couple
years this is great
a couple years then you threw yourself
again into into a you know this
environment
and i'd love to i'd love to uh
understand a little bit better
a little bit better about your insights
from the running those two accelerators
specifically this whole notion of
breaking into the u.s market i think
it's something that's extremely
fascinating
uh both for startups that are starting
out in the us market but also for
a lot of my friends around europe and
israel who are running their companies a
lot of them are
are considering when to relocate i'm
very very good friends with julie and
gil from upwest and yeti and guy from
from fusion la and and so there's a lot
of talk about
how to help outside companies break into
the us market and i'd love to hear a
little bit about your insight from doing
that both from the accelerator
and then we'll transition also into your
work with angular ventures
of course um yeah so the first when i
came back to new york
i started working at the german
accelerator and that program
was about bringing german startups to
the u.s market
i think that germany um was ahead of the
game there it was actually a program
sponsored by the german government so
wow zero equity zero fees
wow everything yeah which is very
special and
i think germany rightfully realized that
the way to you know long term
grow their economy was really investing
in their startups and a big part of that
investment is helping them come to the
us
i think that this is something that's
especially true
for companies that are b2b especially
enterprise
right just because um so many of the
largest companies are based in the us
and being able to meet with them and you
know
get their feedback and bring them on as
design partners
is so vitally important so
that program you know i ran that program
as a program manager
for two years and then um you know also
saw that there was a big appetite for
startups um who wanted to come to the us
from other parts of the world i know
israel that's been
so ingrained in the israeli ecosystem
for so long that for the
for israelis it's like obviously this is
a no-brainer
but for a lot of other countries it was
less obvious i think too
for startups say from france or from um
you know italy or germany there can be
that fallacy of like my market is big
enough
right i can go to the top french
companies and grow it through there
but ultimately you tap out of your
market really quickly
and by the time you're like okay i
conquer the french market now it's time
to go to the us
you could have a competitor here that's
already
taken over the market and you might be
put at a serious disadvantage
so we saw that there was this need so i
co-founded um
ls accelerator and we ran three
different cohorts
through that program and that was all
about you know bringing companies
from all around the world to the us and
um
you know it worked pretty well i'd say
that the biggest
reasons for startups to think about
coming to the us
and obviously things the way you do that
now with code is a bit different than
the way you did it before
um but the reasons are still
fundamentally the same right
sales acceleration so we've actually
done a bit of research
and for more than 80 percent of startups
that come to the u.s their sales
drastically increased
really 80 83 83
that's well yeah um and then also it's
much easier to fundraise right there's a
lot of
investors in the u.s there's a lot of
money flowing
um and so for about 40 of the startups
that came here
they had an easier process um
fundraising
and i do have to ask anne because i
obviously there is this
you know the mindset shift is is a
challenge by on its uh on its own right
so providing that accessibility into the
american mindset and
and actually making that move of of
transitioning the business towards the
us market
but what what other challenges did you
notice whether it's through the german
accelerator
or else what what are some of the common
challenges that that companies or early
stage companies face
as they come to the us and they're
seeing like wow like this is something
either we didn't expect or wow this is
like a hurdle that we're facing along
with a lot of other newcomers here
i think there's a lot of challenges um
and a lot of some of them are foreseen
some of them are not
i would say an interesting thing you
know especially
i'm based in in new york a lot of
founders that come here
and they're just like blown away by how
expensive everything is
right like you come here sure office is
expensive town is expensive
everything's expensive and so i would
say going into it like be prepared to
make an investment because it will
there will be a lot of upfront costs so
that's one thing it's just the
it's it's a big investment just from a
time perspective and also
a capital perspective i would say
managing the culture
is is quite difficult when you now
listen i have team
in the us in israel right time zone
makes it challenging to me
um when you're hiring american employees
the culture there can be some clash
where you know
people you're both speaking english but
you may still not be able to understand
what
the other person is saying um implicitly
and
then i would say to another track that a
lot of startups i see fall into
is hiring the wrong people you see this
especially with
sales people american sales people are
really good at selling themselves
and especially for someone coming from
outside the us
they hear them and like they talk about
their sales experience and it's like
this is perfect you know
this person is going to grow our sales
funnel tremendously and then a couple
months down the line
it doesn't work you know i would
honestly say that like
most times the initial sales people
don't end
um so you know the advice i'd give there
is like be very very careful who you
bring on to
the team um you know high or slow and if
they don't work out like if you're even
thinking about letting someone go let
him go right higher slow player faster
exactly um you know and i think that's
that holds true
um both domestically and when you're in
the us
um but especially because salaries are
more expensive here
it can be very costly to keep someone on
if they're not
you know bringing in real revenue 100
and i want to make sure we'll seven
enough time to talk about angular
ventures because i think that
you know being head of platform for uh
for an early stage fund um you know you
know
the mission is very is very clear and
something that i really really resonate
to and
and it's it's not too far off from what
you were doing with the two other
accelerators
but now you're doing it with a head of a
vc and you're doing it with portfolio
companies that that you have a stake in
right so it's no longer
just companies that are coming in and
they're asking for help but you actually
you have a stake in the game
talk to me a little bit about what
angular ventures is and what is your
specific role within that
fund that is bridging the gap between
basically the whole world
absolutely um so basically angular
ventures is an early stage fund
that invests in startups from europe and
israel
and will typically do checks from
anywhere from 200
000 to 1.5 million we do lead we do
follow on
um our focus is deep tech enterprise
um about half of our portfolio currently
is
israeli-based or israeli founders and
the other half is
spread out throughout europe and um i
met gildabner the partner of the fund
about a
year before the fund officially closed
for fund one um and i was always
intrigued by venture capital
i wasn't necessarily pursuing it because
it you know i was happy in the
accelerator world
but um i was really interested with what
gil was doing his track records
really impressive i mean four out of 30
investments that he's made have become
unicorns
and then the idea of working um
in a situ because the the downside with
working in the accelerator world right
is you're working with these companies
super intensely
for three months right and then it's
like little birds they fly away
and they go do their own thing and yeah
you obviously still keep in touch but
it's not the same level
of work um whereas
in the vc world and this was something
that really appealed to me is that you
can have this
long-term relationship with these
founders
again at the absolute earliest stage you
know we'll do checks with someone with
just an idea right there can be
we like getting in very very early and
um
help them build their company from the
ground up
so and then work with them for 10 years
plus maybe
um and so that was incredibly appealing
to me and then also the idea
having founded my own company before i
love the idea of
being the first platform hire and
building the platform
up from um from the ground up
and you know fortunately i would say
that gail the partner of the fund he
is very dedicated to working with the
portfolio companies as well so he spends
about half his time working with
existing companies and um the other half
obviously working on on deal flow and
evaluating new opportunities and of
course that shifts
with the covid epidemic or sorry the
copen pandemic
um you know like other like many other
vcs we were
primarily focused on on our own
portfolio even though we were still
doing deals actively um but just making
sure that the portfolio will survive and
and thrive during this time of course so
you know we've built some few really
exciting things on the platform side
ultimately our goal is to be supportive
of our founders
and their startups and ensure that they
have all the resources and connections
they need in order to be successful
so i would say some of the most more
interesting or impactful things that we
offer
the portfolio companies are we have
about a dozen advisory partners
which include uh founders like we have
the two unicorn founders from
from jfrog and science and we also have
subject matter experts from like
branding marketing
sales um etc so
whenever any of our portfolio companies
have a need
on one of these key areas we'll pair
them with these advisory partners and
then we work long term together
um so often times working together for a
year or more
um so it's a really deep relationship
we also want to focus on things that
really move the needle
and especially working with enterprise
startups
the contract sizes for customers can be
so big that if we can help them
get one new client you know we've done
our job
so we do focus a lot on bridging um the
corporates in our network with this
portfolio
um companies in our um to make sure to
see if there's any possibility for like
design partnerships
or for the corporate potential to become
customers ultimately
um we've done a few really interesting
research reports
so at the start of the pandemic we
looked at how
covid was impacting startups um from
you know how many of them were changing
their product to you know doing layoffs
so
what exactly were the sort of founders
thinking of
through at this time um we just released
last week
a report on enterprise deep tech pc in
europe and israel so
if anyone's interested in reading that
it's up on medium definitely encouraged
to check it out
and then we're right now working with
index ventures specifically talking
or looking at how um
israeli startups can successfully expand
to the us market which is of course
top of mind for a lot of founders a
hundred percent so and
before we anna i have to go back and
look at your journey a little bit more
holistically because
you've you've gone through so many
different different experiences
a lot of them are are you know in the
same line of thought of how do we
work with early-stage companies to
either help them break into the u.s
market or
or continue to scale and grow and i'd
love to hear from you
some of the insights that you've gained
throughout the years if you were to look
back and talk to a young entrepreneur
or a young person that's going into the
tech scene or any scene
what are some key things that they
should keep in mind as they go on their
career path
so basically what are some career tips
okay i actually i have quite a few of
these um a lot of these i had to learn
the hard way
yep so and now i get to now i get to
hear them the easy way
so if this helps one person you know
hopefully it's worth it um with the
trials and tribulations i went through
so i would say um i have five tips for
people who
are in their career and um
that for me have been quite valuable so
the first
is storytelling everything at the end of
the day
is about how you can create an
interesting and compelling story
whether you're in college trying to land
a job
right you have to create a good story
about why what you've done in the past
is relevant for the company why
you know your value-add for the specific
company whether you're a founder
that's creating a story about um you
know
why an investor should invest in your
specific company so i think storytelling
is really important
for me and my career
i use storytelling when i
was pivoting out of hr and went to
facebook
and the way that i focused on it was
rather than
focusing on the fact that i was in hr it
was like no i was running programming
for tech right which is very relevant to
writing a startup program
at facebook um and then
i would say another thing that's really
important is
very few things are
worth being the hill to die on i've been
um
guilty of this yeah so basically what
that means
is don't ruin professional relationships
trying to prove your point right i've
been
guilty of this at times especially early
on in my career where it's like you know
the right answer
or you think you know the right answer
and you really want to like
make sure the team or your company does
it that way
and it can you know definitely backfire
on you if you're
really like holding steady on this so
what i
do now is um say my
my thoughts and what i think we should
do and if leadership wants to do it
awesome if not fine um just not getting
as like personally invested
i will caveat that by saying there are
some some things which are
worth being the hill to die on i've
personally encountered one of them
and it was literally if we don't do this
i will walk away from company like
that's
so you know it does happen occasionally
but i think ultimately
you know be very mindful of not rooting
your relationships
because your teammates you have to work
with them you know this project is going
to
be over at some point you know soon but
the teammates if you're working at this
company for years
you have to continue working with them
so i think it's really important to have
positive relationships with them
i have to say regarding regarding that
point it's it's so interesting i
remember i
i often reflect back to my officers
academy training and
i remember that one of my commanders
there she she gave us a talk about you
know our values and and the things that
we are
really passionate about and especially
now in a military setting it's often a
very interesting balance between
you know the things that you believe in
the things that the system believes in
at the end
you have a very you know you know your
role within an organization and you know
it
it's perhaps it's accelerated within in
a military organization because the
thing you're working towards is
different than just you know monetary
value for the company
but one of the things she told us is
that you really have one chance within
an organization
uh to choose something that is worth
fighting for enough that you are saying
i'm putting my keys down and if and if
this is not happening then i'm walking
away but you only get to do that once
really
because the second time the third time
it doesn't really work so so
i i definitely i haven't used that card
yet in any organization but
but i definitely see i i can't you know
20 minutes ago go by so fast and and i
obviously there are so many more things
that that i can learn from but but
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
yeah um absolutely so i would say
if i had to use three words to describe
myself the first
is being determined so if i get an idea
in my head whether it's in
like work or in my personal life like it
will happen like come hell or high water
i will make it happen
um and so that's it
career-wise it's been pretty helpful um
and then i would say
i i tend to be pretty resilient um
there's been a number of times where
i had to face things that were pretty
challenging and
a few times where i had to completely
start from scratch right when i moved
back to new york
after leaving facebook i didn't have an
apartment you know i was staying at my
friend's place
didn't have a job so you know completely
rebuilding my life from scratch i think
it takes a lot of resiliency to do that
and do it well and i think
a lot of people right now you know the
entire everyone needs to be resilient
going through what we're going through
and
and managing and doing so successfully
so i think that that's a really
important skill to have
um and then lastly i would say kindness
um there's that
uh famous line that goes um you know
nice guys finished last and i think that
is
absolutely not true i think in the short
term being a vacuum rebellion can pay
off
but long term it 100 does not pay off
because people
will learn that about you and then they
just will not want to work with you so i
think being kind
both personal life and professional life
is 100
the right way and it's worked really
well for me and
thank you very very much thanks for
being so generous with your time and for
all the inspiration and insights through
all this
it was really wonderful i had a great
time thank you so much for having me
this is an absolute pleasure
of course take care stay safe and stay
healthy
you